if you've been eagerly anticipating the
release of official mod support for
Fallout 4 then good news it looks like
it's coming to pc in april with console
to follow closely after i'm lucy and
welcome to this post-apocalyptic
gamespot news update director Todd god
Howard revealed the information in an
interview with Game Informer he said mod
support will kick off after the first
DLC automat ron has been released we
want to get it up on PC and have it work
it'll probably be a good months before
it hits xbox one and another month for
PlayStation 4 I would also talked about
fallout falls upcoming DLC including the
Pokemon esque automatron and wasteland
workshop he explained the first one
automatron has a little quest line and
this Pokemon s kill robots get their
parts built your own gameplay the
waistline workshop DLC is obviously for
workshop people we wanted it to scratch
that itch of can I build my own
Thunderdome the survival mode was also
revealed to be coming to steams beta
program soon and will come to consoles
when developer Bethesda feels it's ready
for an official release although
official support is still on its way
we've already seen a deluge of mods to
check out some of the best make sure to
take a look at gamespot's fallout
Porsche where Kate and Dave scour the
wasteland for the best mods available so
far for more on fallout 4 make sure to
keep it gamespot
you